GEMMA CHAN
We're from the cast of...
KUMAIL NANJIANI
It's time to play Choose For Eternity!
PHASTOS
Okay, get ready for it!
SALMA HAYEK
Quesadillas!
KUMAIL NANJIANI
It's gotta be biryani.
GEMMA CHAN
Sunday roast with all the trimmings.
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
It's gonna be breakfast for dinner.
Anything with
cheese and eggs, I'm at it!
KINGO
This is really good, Gil!
KUMAIL NANJIANI
Grape Kool-Aid.
SALMA HAYEK
Mezcal!
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
Vanilla milkshakes!
GEMMA CHAN
Vodka!
SALMA HAYEK
My family, and the Eternals.
KUMAIL NANJIANI
I've gotta say my wife, Emily.
Because she might watch this.
GEMMA CHAN
Richard Madden.
KUMAIL NANJIANI
Pajamas.
SALMA HAYEK
Pajamas!
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
A onesie! That has the buttons
in the back,
'cause that's just easy.
KUMAIL NANJIANI
Oh my God!
SALMA HAYEK
Really, you're asking me this?
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
This is the rudest question!
SALMA HAYEK
Mango!
GEMMA CHAN
Chocolate.
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
Bone marrow and cherries!
KINGO
What?
KUMAIL NANJIANI
I feel like vanilla gets, like,
short shrift. Everyone thinks vanilla
is so vanilla, but vanilla's really good!
SALMA HAYEK
Eternals!
KUMAIL NANJIANI
It's gonna sound like I'm biased,
but Marvel Studios' Eternals.
AJAK
It is time.
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
Marvel Studios' Eternals is
in theaters November 5th!
KUMAIL NANJIANI
Book your tickets today!